Perú, ese país que parece cambiar de
gobierno casi tanto como de estaciones,
nos ha dado en los últimos cinco años todo
un espectáculo de inestabilidad política:
6 presidentes, decenas, decenas y decenas de
ministros, y un Congreso totalmente paralizado.
Desde el cese forzado del presidente
Pedro Pablo Kuczynski en marzo del 2018,
las instituciones peruanas parecen haber
entrado en algo así como una tormenta perfecta,
donde cualquiera que se arriesgue a pescar en río
revuelto puede sacar algún botín… Aunque eso sí,
seguramente luego termine como el rosario
de la aurora, esto es, con un enorme caos.
Si no recordemos al malogrado
presidente Pedro Castillo:
llegó a la presidencia con apenas una base
del 18,92% de los votos en primera vuelta,
prometió un gran cambio, protagonizó una
guerra campal con el Congreso y ahora su
gobierno es ya historia y él está en la cárcel.
Ahora bien, en toda esta historia de idas y
vueltas, caos, líos, inestabilidad y
parálisis política… ¿Es cosa solo de
los políticos peruanos o alguien más está
sacando provecho de ello? Pues… Atentos.
El 7 de diciembre del 2022, Dina Boluarte asumió
la presidencia del Perú después de que el anterior
presidente Pedro Castillo intentara llevar un
absurdo, improvisado y mal gestionado golpe
de Estado que terminó expulsándolo del poder.
Y a pesar de que Boluarte procede del núcleo de
poder del gobierno de Castillo, supo pasar página
y romper lazos para hacerse con la presidencia.
Claro, que entonces, numerosos focos de protestas
estallaron a lo largo y ancho de todo el país,
especialmente en las localidades andinas. Por
momentos estas protestas incendiaron el Perú y
para que os hagáis una idea, en el momento
de preparar este vídeo se contabilizan 66
fallecidos y un montón de problemas económicos.
En un primer momento, las manifestaciones tenían
como objetivo pedir la renuncia de Boluarte,
sin embargo, poco a poco en el sur del país,
las protestas tomaron otro tinte muy diferente…
De repente, su objetivo empezó a ser algo mucho
más disruptivos cuyas implicaciones pueden no
solo extenderse en el tiempo, sino, incluso,
amenazar la propia integridad del Perú.
Queridos, amigos, amigas, cada vez
son más los grupos que apuestan por impulsar
un movimiento secesionista a favor de la
independencia del 'Gran Sur' del país.
Ahora bien, ¿hasta qué punto hablamos
de una amenaza real? ¿Qué intereses están detrás
de toda esta historia? ¿Se puede romper el Perú?
Pues bien… Veámoslo.
(T1: UNA HISTORIA LLENA DE ROCES)
Ya sabéis que en VisualPolitik, muchas
veces nos gusta recurrir a la historia
para construir un contexto para la actualidad.
Sin embargo, en este caso, podéis creerme si
os digo que la historia se parece más al
presente de lo que nos podamos imaginar.
Así que para entender dónde nacen
las reivindicaciones independentistas
del Sur del Perú, tenemos que entender
primero cómo se compusieron sus fronteras.
Y es que fijaos, cuándo esta nación se
independizó en el año 1821 se creó el
protectorado de San Martín en el Perú, un
gobierno provisional que tuvo al frente
al “libertador” argentino José Francisco
de San Martín. Claro que al poco tiempo
renunció y le cedió el testigo a la
Suprema Junta Gubernativa del Perú,
una especie de gobierno designado por el
primer Congreso constituyente de este país.
Claro que en ese momento la guerra contra la
corona española todavía continuaba, no solo en
el Perú, sino también la mayor parte de la región.
De esta forma en agosto del año 1825 se proclamó
la independencia de la República de Bolívar, la
cual posteriormente se renombró como Bolivia.
(Y he aquí lo más importante: para muchos esta
nueva nación representaba por sus lazos sociales,
culturales, económicos y hasta territoriales
un claro expansionismo del bolivarianismo en la
zona de influencia de Lima. Así que el choque
entre las distitas facciones estaba servido.)
En 1828, aun con el conflicto con España vivo
en ciertas zonas, los peruanos se organizaron
para lanzar una invasión militar sobre Bolivia,
con el fin de forzar la retirada de Antonio José
de Sucre -leal a Bolívar- de esta zona.
Digamos que los peruanos no se fiaban del
libertador Venezolano. Y bueno,
al fin y al cabo, su gran héroe
de la independencia había sido San Martín.
Pero, ojo, porque esto fue solo el comienzo.
(Entre los años 1834 y 1835 estallaron varios
conflictos en el Perú, en el último de ellos
los rebeldes al entonces gobierno de Felipe
Salaverry buscaron ayuda en el gobierno boliviano,
quien aceptó intervenir en el conflicto. Los
bolivianos lanzaron una excursión militar conocida
como la “Guerra de Pacificación del Perú”.
De esta forma, los rebeldes apoyados por
Bolivia se hicieron con el poder en Lima,
y redoblaron la apuesta, creando en 1836
la Confederación Perú-Boliviana. Ante esta
situación, los peruanos que resistieron buscaron
la ayuda de Chile, quien aceptó contribuir a
la creación de un Ejército Unido Restaurador,
el cual logró revertir la situación en 1839
cuando se dio por disuelta esta Confederación.)
El peor de los miedos para buena parte de
la élite peruana se había hecho realidad.
Bolivia era un actor peligroso y una
auténtica para su soberanía. Así que
pesar de haber acordado una tregua tras la
disolución de la Confederación Perú-Boliviana,
los peruanos invadieron nuevamente Bolivia
en 1841, claro que no tuvieron mucho éxito.
Y al final el Tratado de Puno de 1842 generó
una paz algo más duradera. Una paz que, incluso,
generó algún que otro vínculo
amistoso entre ambos países.
Por ejemplo, en 1879, Bolivia se vio
envuelta en otro conflicto militar,
en este caso con Chile, fue la denominada
“Guerra del Pacífico”, donde Perú acudió en
auxilio del ejército boliviano por un Tratado
de Alianza Defensiva que se había llegado a
firmar en secreto en 1873. ¡Menudo jaleo!
MAPA: Estados Unidos Perú-Bolivianos
(Este período, además, es clave porque, en 1880,
cuatro años antes de que se alcanzará la paz,
ambos países habían llegado a consensuar
un plan legislativo conjunto para crear
los Estados Unidos Perú-Bolivianos,
aunque al final ese proyecto no cuajó.)
Ya lo veis, toda una historia de amor y odio:
de convivir juntos en una confederación,
a invadirse constantemente entre sí, para
luego apoyarse en una guerra común contra
Chile… El caso es que la idea de volver a vivir
en un mismo país quedó completamente desplazada
en el siglo XX, claro que tarde o temprano
alguien podría volver a tomar esa bandera.
EL REVISIONISMO BOLIVARIANO)
Queridos amigos, amigas, a estas
alturas creó que sabemos que si
los movimientos populistas tienen
alguna adicción esa no es otra que
reescribir los libros de historia, para,
por supuesto, formar un relato a su favor.
Esto es algo que durante la construcción
del llamado Socialismo del Siglo XXI,
sucedió en múltiples sentidos.
¿Queréis una prueba? Pues… Fijaos.
La revolución bolivariana llegó a convertir en
una especie de líder socialista a Simón Bolívar,
un miembro de la oligarquía de la época del
que Karl Marx decía lindezas como estas:
C1(“(Bolívar) es el canalla más
cobarde, brutal y miserable” – Karl
Marx en una carta a Friedrich Engels, 1858. )
Pues bien, el caso es que esto no fue un vicio
exclusivo de la revolución bolivariana.
Cuándo Evo Morales llegó al poder en
Bolivia en 2006 también empezó a jugar con la
historia… En este caso el relanzamiento de la
Confederación Peruana tomó cada vez más peso:
Claro que no solo fue cosa de Evo.
Eventualmente el presidente peruano, Ollanta
Humala, quien gobernó el país entre 2011 y 2016,
también empezó a compartir el
“sueño de morales”. Fijaos.
De hecho, cada dos por tres metía mensajes en sus
redes sociales sobre esta antigua confederación.
Su empeño en reflotar y liderar esta bandera
parece bastante pero que bastante claro.
(30 de octubre de 2021: “Es "un momento de
reafirmar la identidad porque nos alberga el
mismo suelo, la misma historia, sueño y esperanza.
No miramos límites entre Perú y Bolivia.
“Estar en La Paz, estar en Bolivia
es igual que estar en Chota,
la cuna que me vio nacer,
la tierra de donde vengo"
Pedro Castillo, expresidente del Perú)
Ya lo veis, poco a poco la idea de recrear
una nueva nación conjunta fue cogiendo fuerza.
Claro que en 2019 su principal impulso,
Evo Morales, perdió el poder… Lo que,
queridos amigos, amigas, no hizo que sus
esfuerzos se disiparan, sino todo lo contrario.
(T3. RUNASUR… EL PUNTO DE INFLEXIÓN)
En diciembre de 2020 Evo Morales dio
a conocer la creación de RUNASUR,
una entidad cuyo nombre surge de
la UNIÓN de las palabras “Runa”:
«persona» en quechua; y UNASUR, la
Unión de Naciones Suramericanas.
Supuestamente, esta organización tenía
como objetivo servir como mecanismo de
integración plurinacional entre los
pueblos indígenas, afrodescendientes,
organizaciones sociales, sindicales, territoriales
y movimientos sociales de la región”. Todo junto.
Pues bien, en esta entidad se aglomeran
los principales movimientos indigenistas
de izquierdas en la región. Algunos de ellos,
incluso, con un enorme poder de movilización,
como es el caso de la Confederación de
Nacionalidades Indígenas de Ecuador, quien,
por ejemplo, en junio de 2022 puso en jaque
las políticas económicas de Guillermo Lasso.
Runasur ha supuesto un auténtico de
inflexión: a los antecedentes históricos,
a las múltiples llamadas de Evo a la
reunificación boliviana-peruana ahora
se suma una plataforma con poder
de movilización y organización.
Ahora la crisis política en Perú puede
haber encendido la mecha. Ahora bien,
¿En qué piensa Evo Morales cuándo habla
de reunificación? ¿Qué tiene en mente?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
(T4 AGITANDO EL AVISPERO)
Con todo lo que Evo Morales parece
haber soñado con la reunificación de
la Confederación Perú-Boliviana, es evidente que
la llegada de Pedro Castillo era una oportunidad
única para avanzar hacia esa dirección:
N3(26 de julio de 2021: Evo Morales llegó
a Perú para asistir a la asunción de Castillo.
El exmandatario boliviano (2006-19) llamó a los
Gobiernos de ambos países a diseñar una "agenda
binacional", y agregó: "Sería el mejor homenaje
a nuestros próceres que intentaron la unidad
en la Confederación Peruano Boliviana”. Ámbito)
Sin embargo, la caída de Castillo y el cambio
de gobierno supuso que nuevamente ese proyecto,
esa nueva bandera de Evo Morales quedaba en
saco roto… Excepto si la ingobernabilidad, el
caos y las protestas fueran capaces de alimentar
que una mayoría social comprase ese discurso.
Y como decimos por aquí, dicho y hecho.
N4(El fantasma de una secesión aparece en
medio de la crisis política peruana. Telam)
C3("(Los limeños) nos quitan el derecho a
consulta popular, a nuestro presidente
que hemos elegido mayoritariamente (Pedro
Castillo) lo tienen secuestrado; están
asesinando y los muertos son del sur,
no del centro ni del norte" Felipe
Dominguez, líder del Frente de
Defensa del Cono Norte de Arequipa.)
N5(9 de enero de 2023: Perú prohíbe el
ingreso de Evo Morales por afectar "la seguridad
nacional". En los últimos meses se ha identificado
a ciudadanos extranjeros, de nacionalidad
boliviana, que ingresaron al país para efectuar
actividades de índole política [..] remarcó el
Ministerio del Interior en un comunicado. DW)
C4(26 de enero de 2023: "Declaramos persona
no grata al señor Evo Morales Auma en el
territorio nacional, por sus constantes
incitaciones en la política nacional,
las mismas que buscan desequilibrar el orden
interno del país, en especial la zona del sur del
Perú. Moción presentada por la congresista María
del Carmen Alva y aprobada con 74 votos a favor.)
Ahora bien, ¿en qué está pensando
Evo cuando habla de la reunificación?
Estrictamente, no habla de la unión de los dos
países, sino de la secesión de una parte del Perú
para constituir una república que luego podría
formar una especie de confederación con Bolivia.
En concreto, el proyecto pasaría por la
creación de una República independiente,
donde tomen parte los departamentos de
Arequipa, Ayacucho, Apurímac, Cusco,
Madre de Dios, Moquegua, Puno y Tacna. Estas
zonas son muy ricas en recursos minerales,
y abarcan a 6 de los 33 millones
de habitantes que tiene el Perú.
En este escenario la localidad más apegada
a la idea de la independencia sería Puno,
no tanto por la crisis político como sobre
todo por aspectos económicos y culturales.
C5("El sur de Puno es culturalmente muy similar al
altiplano boliviano. Hay una cercanía muy grande,
que se nota en las costumbres y en cómo se viste
la gente, y también en episodios históricos como
el intento de establecer una Confederación
peruano-boliviana en 1836". Ramiro Escobar,
experto en Relaciones Internacionales de la
Pontificia Universidad Católica del Perú,)
Por eso Punto ha sido, precisamente, uno es uno
de los epicentros de las principales protestas,
paros y bloqueos de vías en contra de
Dilma Boluarte. En la zona operan lo que la
presidenta describió como los “Ponchos rojos”,
una agrupación de manifestantes bolivianos que
presuntamente estarían traficando armas para
promover una escalada de violencia en la zona.
Y, ojo, porque estos movimientos van más
allá de las protestas que se produjeron
tras la caída de Castillo. Digamos que
tienen un proyecto de mucho más largo
plazo. Y no, no hablamos de la vía armada.
Todo apunta a que la idea sería buscar un
camino constituciones que facilite el proyecto del
expresidente boliviano en un futuro no muy lejano.
Atentos.
(T5
¿UNA NUEVA CONSTITUCIÓN A
LA VUELTA DE LA ESQUINA?)
Desde que dio comienzo el 2023, diferentes
encuestas han mostrado un alto nivel de apoyo
popular a la idea de reformar o, incluso,
generar una nueva Constitución en el Perú.
Y, claro, aprobar una nueva Constitución con tanta
convulsión social… Puede terminar abriendo las
puertas para que se apruebe de todo. Y, ¿Sabéis
qué? Evo Morales parece tenerlo muy claro. Fijaos.
C6(“Algunos pequeños grupos aprovechando la
prensa (me van) declarando persona no grata,
(dicen que) Evo no debe entrar a Perú,
pero el verdadero pueblo, pueblo,
¿cómo sería si entraría a Perú? ¿te imaginas
en este momento? Sería una aclamación, como una
proclamación” Evo Morales, 29 de enero de 2023.)
Queridos amigos, amigas, últimamente el Perú no
va por buen camino. Os hemos hablado de
ello tanto aquí en VisualPolitik como en
nuestro canal hermano VisualEconomik.
Y la verdad es que si algo está claro,
es que entre unas cosas y otras la clase
política peruana está consiguiendo echar por
tierra la que era una de las economías
más prometedoras de América Latina.
Los movimientos independentistas
pueden terminar convirtiéndose
en el último jaque al estado peruano.
Pero, llegados hasta aquí…. Turno para ti.
¿Sabías que Perú y Bolivia han tenido un
pasado con tanto amor y odio? ¿Crees que Evo
Morales se saldrá con la suya y logrará
alimentar un amplio movimiento social
en favor de la independencia? Y quizás la pregunta
más importante: ¿Conseguirá romper el Perú?
Déjanos por aquí abajo tus comentarios
y abramos debate. Y por supuesto,
si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante no olvides darle a
like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik
si es que aún no lo has hecho.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.